hi my name is Shane glass and I'm the
program manager for Google clouds public
data sets program I'm here today to talk
to you about the public data sets we
host in bigquery and Google Cloud
Storage and how these data sets can help
you more easily unlock new insights in
your existing data we currently have
more than 130 data sets in the public
data sets program these data sets are
on-boarded and maintained by Googlers
with input and guidance from data
providers you can see here a sample of
our weather and climate data providers
including NOAA NASA the European Space
Agency and the US Geological Survey
among others
our bigquery public data sets can be
joined with your existing data to help
you uncover new insights more easily
datasets like the global surfer summary
of the day which provides meteorological
observations at weather stations around
the world every day going back more than
100 years can for instance help you
better understand how weather might
impact sales patterns for your business
we're constantly adding new data sets
and here are just two examples of
recently added unstructured data sets
both coming from NOAA the National
Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration
these are the high-resolution rapid
refresh model which includes
fine-grained wind data at various
altitudes and the national water model
which has information about flooding and
water movement across the continental
United States you can learn more about
the data we make available for use in
the GCP marketplace here you'll find an
overview of the data and samples to help
you get started you can go there now to
explore what's available and start
learning more from your data thank you